[Music]
the annual BTT awards were last night
that's right I hope yeah thank you thank
you
I thought I did a great job the beauty
Awards were last night and one moment
that everyone is talking about is the
acceptance speech given by actor Jesse
Williams now he won the Humanitarian
Award and he gave this incredibly moving
speech about contemporary black
oppression everyone's talking about it
here's a clip if you have a critique for
the resistance for all resistance and
you better have an established record of
critique of our oppression if you have
no interest in equal rights for black
people then do not make suggestions to
those who do sit down it was an
incredible speech she talked about
racial injustice and the co-opting of
black culture everybody was on their
feet at the end and well frankly that's
why I felt really sorry for the musical
act that followed him Petey wants to
bring that lansing michigan to do swing
up in here
ladies put your boobies together ya know
come on Spike Lee you got the back
come on let's get some energy business
please go go I just want to get serious
for a minute here and talk about racism
do do do man
okay that was horribly timed not I'm
just trying to make a point but as a kid
I used to watch nothing but The Cosby
Show
not mention Cosby right now
do the math unfortunate timing
you